thank you very much everyone for being
here today it's my pleasure to introduce
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin III
and chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Mark milley the secretary
and the chairman will each deliver
opening remarks and then have time to
take a few questions
please note I will moderate those
questions and call on journalists and
would ask that you limit your follow-ups
due to our tight schedule today and I
appreciate your assistance with us
secretary Austin over to you sir
well good afternoon everybody
and we just concluded our 10th highly
successful meeting of
Ukraine defense contact group
but before I get to that important work
I want to say just a few words about a
troubling episode yesterday
on Tuesday Russian aircraft again
engaged in dangerous
and Reckless and unprofessional behavior
in the international airspace over the
Black Sea
the two Russian Jets not fueled on an
unmanned U.S MQ-9 aircraft conducting
routine operations
in international airspace
and one Russian jet struck our MQ-9
aircraft resulting in a crash
this hazardous episode is a part
is part of a pattern of aggressive risk
and risky and unsafe actions by Russian
pilots and international airspace
now I just got off the phone with my
Russian counterpart minister shoyu
as I said repeatedly it's important that
great Powers be models of transparency
and communication
in the United States will continue to
fly and to operate wherever
international law allows
and it is incumbent upon Russia to
operate as military aircraft
in a safe and professional manner
now
let me turn to the important work of
this contact group
today our extraordinary allies and
partners reaffirmed
our unity and resolve in supporting
Ukraine's fight
for freedom
we were joined again today by some 50
nations of Goodwill from all around the
globe
and they all understand that Ukraine's
battle to defend itself
from Russian aggression
is vital for everyone who values the
core principles of sovereignty
self-determination
and freedom
today we will join the gang by my good
friend Minister Alexi reznikov
he comes to each contact group meeting
with a clear message
for the next steps in Ukraine's
resistance to Russia's campaign of
Conquest
and the presentations from him and his
team
underscore the continued urgency of our
support
this contact group has pushed hard to
ensure that Ukraine can defend itself
from Putin's Imperial aggression
Brave ukrainians stood firm during
Russia's ground invasion
with the help of their new anti-tank and
anti-aircraft missiles which contact
group countries have provided
Russia's Russia hopes to grind down
Ukraine in a war of attrition
but Ukraine has been supplied by more
than 40 countries
meanwhile Russia has
had to depend on Iran and North Korea
and it's had to use equipment dating
back to World War II
so Russia is running out of capability
and running out of France
Putin has now had a Year's worth of
proof that the United States and the
contact group will support Ukraine's
right to defend itself
for the Long Haul
but Putin still hopes that he can wear
down Ukraine and wait us out
so we can't let up
and we won't
Ukraine doesn't have any time to waste
and I heard clearly today that our
fellow contact group members also know
that we have to deliver swiftly and
fully on our promised commitments
and that includes delivering
our armored capabilities to the
battlefield
and ensuring that Ukrainian soldiers get
the get the training spare parts and
maintenance support that they need to
use these new systems as soon as
possible
and we'll continue to dig deep for new
donations
and today we heard updates on our
progress
and some significant new commitments
Sweden has announced that it will
provide Ukraine with 10 leopard tanks
and key air defense components
Norway is partnering with the United
States to donate to nasam systems to
Ukraine
the Netherlands is making great progress
in initi initiating new contracts to
ensure that new capabilities continue to
arrive on the battlefield
and I want to thank Slovenia for its
latest contribution
which helps meet several of Ukraine's
priority requirements including armor
for more than a year now farsighted
donations like these by members of this
contact group have been crucial to
Ukraine's fight for sovereignty
and we have provided crucial combat
capabilities that Ukraine's Defenders
will use to further repel Russia's
invasion into exercise initiative
and to create favorable conditions on
the battlefield
but for Ukraine to protect its Sovereign
territory and defend its citizens over
the long term
we must keep going
so we're going to help Ukraine sustain
the tanks
the Infantry fighting vehicles
and other armored vehicles that are
making their way into the front lines
we're going to continue urgently
training Ukrainian soldiers
on the capabilities that we're providing
and on a combined arms maneuver tactics
that they need to succeed
we're going to keep looking into our
stocks and into our budget
to resupply Ukraine throughout the year
and we're going to continue to continue
our important work in lockstep with our
Ukrainian Partners to maintain
accountability for the security
assistance that we're providing
and finally above all we're going to
stay United
together we're helping Ukraine fight to
live free
together we're helping to show that
rules matter
and together we're helping to advance
our shared Security in an open world
of rules and rights
and so thank you very much and I'll now
turn it over to the chairman for his
comments
good afternoon everyone and thank you
secretary Austin for your leadership uh
this says secretary pointed out as our
10th contact group and these meetings
and the donations that come from it
would not be happening without the
incredible leadership of secretary
Austin so thank you for that your
direction remains critical to the future
success of the group and also uh thank
you to the Ukrainian Minister of Defense
resnikov Mike counterpart General
zaluzny who was not on the call today
but I've talked to him several times in
the past week and the deputy chief of
defense and representative General
zaluzzi General moisu all of them
continue to lead ukrainians military in
their fight for freedom also thanks to
all the ministers in defense and the
chiefs of Defense from 51 participants
in today's meeting including NATO and
the European Union
they joined the meeting and they
continue to provide critical support to
Ukraine each nation is contributing what
they can to ensure Ukraine has the means
to defend itself against the illegal and
unprovoked Russian invasion
it's been nearly 13 months
since Russia invaded The Sovereign
Nation of Ukraine
Ukraine has been independent since 1991.
and has presented no threat whatsoever
to Russia
Russia launched and has continued for
over a year now a war of aggression and
flagrant violation of international law
this is and remains a Russian frontal
assault on the rules-based international
order that has been in place for 80
years eight decades since the end of
World War II
in the face of this act of aggression in
a war of Conquest
this group remains Unified
NATO is United the people of Ukraine are
on yielding they are standing steadfast
in the face of the Russian onslaught
Russia remains isolated
their military stocks are rapidly
depleted the soldiers are demoralized
untrained unmotivated conscripts and
convicts
in their leadership is failing them
having already failed in their strategic
objectives Russia is increasingly
relying on other countries such as Iran
and North Korea as the secretary pointed
out they're using Iranian drones to
continue to terrorize Ukrainian
civilians
this relationship is built on the cruel
bonds of oppressing Freedom subverting
Liberty and maintaining their tyranny
yet free people will not return
to the shackles of tyranny
ukrainians remain defiant with steel in
their spines and courage in their veins
and they have the broad support of the
United States and the International
Community
the Battle of Bach move continues
but Ukraine is fighting with Valor with
robust defenses Ukraine has fixed the
Russian forces at that City and they're
exacting very heavy costs in the Wagner
group and the Russian regular military
Ukraine remains strong
they are capable and trained Ukrainian
soldiers are strength strong in their
combat units their tanks infantry
fighting vehicles and armored vehicles
are only going to bolster the front line
Ukrainian Precision Munitions continue
to Target the logistics and
communication systems of Russia
lacking effective small unit leaders and
absent the proper equipment this is a
grinding attrition Warfare
that Russia is trying to execute
wave after wave of Russian soldiers are
thrown into the chaos of War absent any
sort of synchronized coordination and
direction
Russia continues to pay severely in
terms of lives and military equipment
for its continued war of choice
right now there's intense fighting in
and around Bachman and the Russians are
making small tactical advances but at
Great cost
elsewhere the front line remains
relatively static with significant
exchanges of artillery but no
significant maneuver gains by either
side
right now as you know there's a
significant ongoing effort to build up
the Ukrainian military in terms of
equipment Munitions and training in a
variety of countries in order to enable
Ukraine to defend itself
The increased Ukrainian capability will
allow the Ukrainian leadership to
develop and execute a variety of options
in the future to achieve their
objectives and bring this war to a
successful conclusion
this is an act of brutal aggression by
President Putin and the Russian military
with complete disregard for human life
both civilian and Military
the Russians are wantingly killing
civilians in large attacks and civilian
infrastructure and densely populated
urban areas
severely under trained poorly LED fully
equipped Russian forces are conducting
mindless frontal attacks and sacrificing
hundreds per day
the political objectives that Putin
intended to achieve 384 days ago are
obvious to the world and it should be
obvious to Putin that these objectives
are no longer achievable by continuing
this war
and Putin can end this war and he can
end it today and he needs to do so
freed people are not easily conquered
and the Ukrainian people are free and
they will never give up in their fight
to stay free
two weeks ago the United States released
another security assistance package
which included High Mars ammunition
artillery
vehicle maintenance and vehicles
the nine countries have placed over 150
leopard tanks for example this group
that met today is providing Air Defense
Artillery
regular artillery rocket artillery armor
ammunition and that'll be critical to
Ukraine's ability to continue the fight
a broad mix of air defense systems have
been promised and they will protect the
Skies of a cave in the free cities of
Ukraine artillery and armor are going to
strengthen Ukraine lines enable their
forces to synchronize fire and movement
for either offensive or defensive
operations long-range fires would
challenge Russia's ability to command
and control and protect and sustain
their forces
Ukrainian soldiers wear the blue and
yellow of the Ukrainian flag but the
colors of 50 other nations they've met
today
stand beside Ukraine to support the
principles of the rural space
International order
a system in place to prevent aggression
and uphold the values of Liberty and
sovereignty
that system is what preserves the peace
and provides benefit throughout the
globe as President Biden secretary
Austin and many others to include all
the leaders of Europe have said many
times that we will remain committed for
as long as it takes thank you and I look
forward to your question thank you
gentlemen first question we'll go to
Alito Baldor Associated Press thank you
um Mr secretary you said you spoke with
your counterpart can you give us a sense
of the Russian's reaction to the call
did they suggest to you their defense
that this was an accident or intentional
or that it never happened
um can you just give us a better read
out of your call and general milley have
you spoken to your counterpart or are
you intending to do so and do you
believe after what you've seen that this
was intentional is this considered an
act of War
I'll wait for the question leader
um
I won't speak for minister shoegu nor
would I will I get into the details
I'll just reiterate
that the United States will fly and
operate forever international law allows
now
we take any potential for escalation
very seriously and that's why
I believe it's important to keep the
lines of communication open
I think it's really key that uh we're
able to pick up the phone and engage
each other and I think that that will
help to prevent miscalculation going
forward
so Alita thanks for the question on the
intentionality don't know I do plan to
talk to uh Mike Connor Park General
grismoff we have a schedule call we'll
see if that works out
um so it wasn't intentional or not don't
know yet we know that the intercept was
intentional we know that the aggressive
behavior was intentional we also know it
was very unprofessional and very unsafe
the actual contact of the fixed-wing uh
Russian fighter with our UAV the
physical contact of those two not sure
yet that remains to be seen uh but I
can't uh I can tell you with certainty
though that we have absolute evidence of
of the contact and intercepts Etc and
it's very aggressive you've heard about
the dumping of the fuel and everything
else we have video evidence and all that
so
um there's no question that that part of
its intentional the actual physical
contact of the aircraft that I'm not so
sure so we'll have to figure that out
that we're not we're not positive of
that game as far as an active War goes
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go there
incidents happen
um and and clearly we do not uh seek
armed conflict with uh with Russia and
uh and and I believe that uh uh at this
point we should investigate this
incident and move on from there but we
will continue to exercise our rights in
international airspace
let's go to download Washington Post
gentlemen thank you for your time today
uh secretary Austin uh announced an
likely presidential candidates already
have declared that Ukraine should not be
an American priority uh given that the
Biden Administration has promised to
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
are you concerned that election rhetoric
could undermine uh support for Ukraine
in Congress or with the American people
and then chairman Noe uh the MQ-9 came
down in the Black Sea where the United
States has not had any military vessels
for more than a year
is it fair to say that the U.S will not
recover this MQ-9 and do you have any
concerns about what value it might have
to Russia either strategically or for
propaganda thank you
um
thanks Dan I would uh
in terms of the importance of Ukraine
first of all we've we've seen bipartisan
support for this for providing security
assistance to Ukraine throughout up to
this point
I expect that we'll continue to see that
going forward we've heard some senior
leaders on both sides of the fence
say that and so I expect that that'll
will continue to enjoy that support
well you know Dan Ukraine matters
it matters not to just
Ukraine or to the United States it
matters to the world
this is about the rules-based
international order it's about one
country's ability to uh to wake up one
day and change the borders of its
neighbor and Annex its neighbors
Sovereign territory
and as we've seen countries around the
world don't think that's a good idea and
that's why you've seen 50 countries not
only come to the you know the initial
meetings of the Ukraine defense contact
group but they continue to come back and
they continue to work hard to ensure
that Ukraine gets everything that it
needs to be successful and that will
remain our Focus going forward
so down on the recovery Peak we know
where it landed in the Black Sea it's
probably about maybe four or five
thousand feet of water or something like
that so any recovery operator is really
difficult at that depth by anyone uh
that's first point secondly is uh true
we don't have any ships there but we do
have a lot of allies in front of the
area now we'll work through recovery
operations that's U.S property uh and
we'll we'll leave it at that at this
point but
it probably broke up they're probably
not a lot to recover
as far as uh the loss of anything of
sensitive uh intelligence Etc uh as
normal we would take and we did take
mitigating measures so we are quite
confident that whatever whatever laws of
value is no longer a value
next question we'll go to Ellie Watson
CBS
thanks for doing this secretary Austin
um
Ely mentioned the video we've heard
reports there you're working to d-class
event five video of the incident what
does that video show and when will that
video be released why hasn't it been
released yet and general Millie
secretary Austin talked about the
pattern of behavior how often is Russia
conducting these harassing Maneuvers and
has it increased in recent weeks
my thanks Ellie as as
you know as you said we are still going
through uh videos and
photographs to uh to ascertain what uh
what we can release what we can provide
um but in terms of what the video shows
we remain confident
in the facts that we have conveyed thus
far uh and I that will not that will not
change in terms of you know what
happened and how it happened uh and and
so again we'll work through uh as
quickly as we can to evaluate videos and
if we'll let you know when we have
something that we in terms of video or
Stills that we can provide
in terms of the pattern of behaviorally
um yes this is a part of a pattern of
behavior the United States and Russian
military forces operate in proximity to
each other uh throughout the world we're
operating in the Middle East and Syria
for example uh the uh we have uh areas
up in Alaska that routinely need a
maritime or aerial vessels come in
contact in the in the maritime areas
outside of Hawaii for example but also
obviously in Europe and particularly
so the fact that we operate in proximity
to each other is not particularly
unusual and we do try to establish
deconfliction channels uh in order to
make sure that our forces are physically
separated and we don't have incidents
like this like this but there is a
pattern of behavior recently where
there's a little bit more aggressive
actions being conducted by the Russians
we think we haven't completed our
analysis as to why that's happening and
it wasn't just involving us there was
some incidents early with the British
it's another
so there is a pattern behavior going on
here and we have to figure out exactly
what the way ahead is I think that was
one of the fundamental reasons for
secretaries called Minister shoigu and
one of the reasons for my call to John
Griffin
go to Nancy Youssef Wall Street Durham
thank you General Millie I was wondering
if you could clarify something you said
earlier you said the U.S has a lot of
allies and friends in the region
um referring to the Black Sea it might
it take from that that the US has
prepared to send or request Allied ships
to go in and survey and possibly recover
uh the Drone or is the expectation that
the US has not intended to cover the
term and then secretary Austin I'd like
to go back to some comments you made in
Brussels you said that Baku was largely
symbolic are you concerned that the
Ukrainian investment in Baku potentially
takes away resources that could be
applied to the spring offensive and risk
um the outcome of that offensive thank
you
if you don't mind I'll go first uh Nancy
I
um
first of all let me applaud
The Valor the persistence that we've
seen
from the Ukrainian soldiers
they have done amazing things at Bach
mood
I think the Russians have been working
to take bakmut for some seven months or
so yeah
they haven't been very successful and
that's because of the diligence the
commitment the focus of the
Ukrainian soldiers
in terms of the significance of Bach
moot
I would say I would point to the fact
that president zielinski is fighting
this fight
and he will make the calls on what's
important and what's not important to
his forces and whether he needs to
reposition or remain in Bach moving
the point that I would make is if he
does make a call to reposition at some
point in time it doesn't mean that the
war is lost uh it it may mean and
probably will mean that he is
positioning himself to maintain uh
advance and so I think that's the real
key there but whether or not he stays
there or how long they stay there that's
president zielinski's call and not uh
you know not anybody else's and again
our goal is to make sure that we're
supporting him and whatever decision
he's Battlefield decision he's going to
make and by the way we're generating
combat power to a degree that we believe
that it will provide them opportunities
to change the Dynamics on a battlefield
at some point going forward whatever
point that is whatever you know whatever
they want to do in the future I think
the platforms the the training the
sustainment the maintenance that we're
providing is it will make a significant
difference and as we work through all of
this with our allies and partners in
detail today in the meeting
we are on Pace and that's in large
measure due to the professionalism of
our forces who are conducting the
training and equipping but also forces
around the uh around Europe as the
chairman pointed out and there are there
are a number of countries that are
conducting training in in their
countries they're providing various
platforms uh and uh and we're really
focused on how we're going to sustain
those platforms as well so
and that's on the question of the
recovery piece I wouldn't read too much
into what I said but we do have allies
and Friends of the region we don't have
any Naval surface vessels in the Black
Sea at this time uh and we'll work up
options but as I said at the outset this
is uh probably about four or five
thousand feet of water and it probably
don't know for certain yeah
I have actual facts on the impact on
what debris is there probably sank
to some significant depths so any
recovery operation from a techno
standpoint was very difficult if there
is reason to believe that we could or
recover something then we'll walk up
option for the Secretary of the
president to consider it will move from
there but we do have options and we do
have friends and allies in the region
costume
as chair memory you were in Syria
earlier this month and that visit hit a
lot of headlines in turkey and
eventually the Turkish Ministry of
Foreign Affairs summoned Ambassador
flake to the ministry to provide an
explanation what was the message behind
your visit sir and to secretary Austin
turkey has requested to buy Nev f-16s
and also modernization kits for its
existing Fleet and Ankara is saying that
lack of approval as soon as possible
will not only undermine the Turkish
nation's security but also the security
of NATO so I was I will I would like to
ask your asses your insights on this
assessment and your thoughts about
providing block 70 f-16s to Turkey thank
you
yeah well turkey's a NATO Ally and we
have a strong a long-standing strong
relationship with turkey and we intend
to do everything possible to keep it
that way
um it's real important to us that we
maintain interoperability between our
NATO allies and and so that'll always be
a focus it'll always be a priority
uh as you know typically we don't uh
comment on any pending uh
equipment sales prior to Congress being
notified so I don't have any comments to
make on on that particular FMS case but
uh but again I would just highlight the
fact that turkey remains a very valuable
partner and we'll make sure that we're
doing everything we can to continue to
strengthen our relationship
and um for my visit it was nothing more
than a routine trip visit to determine
the task purpose mission to go out and
check on that see how we're doing and to
assess things like force protection Etc
we've got almost a thousand troops in
Syria and and they are at risk they are
attacked from time to time with various
types of Munitions by various actors
that are in the area of Syria so I want
to go and check on that and to make sure
that the mission is validated and and
come back here and put out to the
secretary
with respect to turkey turkey and the
United States have a common interest
here we have had a common interest for
years we've been there for years and the
common interest is ensure the enduring
defeat of Isis Isis the caliphate was
destroyed but the organization is still
remnants of that organization over there
there's still refugee camps and prison
camps that are there that we're helping
out folks training folks to help secure
this so it's in our interest and it's in
the it's in turkey's interest uh and and
it's for sure something that I needed to
do and it's it's appropriately perfectly
appropriate for the chairman to go check
on how the forces are doing it
especially when they're In Harm's Way
secretary Austin General Millie thank
you very much gentlemen this concludes
the time we have available today thank
you very much
any words about what happens